* Fröhliche Countryklänge:
"Little Bitty" von Alan Jackson *
# Have a little love
on a little honeymoon.
# You got a little dish
and you got a little spoon.
Alright. Honegger?
Spricht sich Ihr Name so aus?
Bitte kommen Sie mit
zu meinem Wagen.
Ja was ... Was denkst du?
Wir waren über 100 und hier ist 75.
Ui.
Es ging halt nur geradeaus ...
- Ja, das ...
Mein Name ist Arthur Honegger.
Acht Jahre lang
waren die USA mein Zuhause.
Arthur Honegger in New York ...
Als Korrespondent bin ich in
dieser Zeit ganz schön rumgekommen.
47 von 50 Bundesstaaten
habe ich besucht.
Auch heute noch beschäftigt mich
dieses grosse, verrückte Land
praktisch nonstop
bei meiner Fernseharbeit.
In dieser Serie will ich nun
mein unbekanntes Amerika entdecken.
Abseits der grossen Politik.
Neue Staaten, neue Menschen,
neue Erfahrungen.
This is my paradise.
Albuquerque,
die grösste Stadt in New Mexico -
und trotzdem so ein Ort,
an den es einen kaum je verschlägt.
Jetzt bin ich hier.
Unsere Reise beginnt am Flughafen,
aber eigentlich wollen wir diesen
Staat ja auf der Strasse erfahren,
im wahrsten Sinn des Wortes.
New Mexico ist road trip country.
Ein langweiliger Mietwagen
kommt da nicht infrage, klar.
Wir brauchen ein Auto mit Charakter.
Beat!
Ja ... Der wäre schön.
- Obviously.
Ja, aber ...
- Shelby.
Stylish soll er sein, unser Wagen,
günstig natürlich -
und so gut beieinander,
dass wir ihn am Ende der Reise
weiterverkaufen können.
Ja, hat weder den Platz,
den wir brauchen,
noch den Preis, den wir uns wünschen.
2'000, max. 3'000 $.
Und Platz für Kameramann Sergio,
Regisseur Beat und mich,
plus Equipment und Gepäck.
Was habt ihr vor mit dem Auto?
Grössere Strecken fahren oder ...
Ja, etwas rumfahren.
Nicht auf viele Berge hoch,
aber doch auf den einen oder anderen.
Da hab ich was für euch.
Frisch überprüft, eingehend.
Ein 2003 Ford Taurus.
Mit nur 200'000 km.
Und der fährt wirklich eins a.
Wie ihr sehen könnt.
Na ja, ein Ford Taurus
ist nicht eben ein Hingucker.
Aber Charakter hat er. Und Platz.
Okay, wir schauen noch etwas rum
und kommen wieder. Danke.
3'500 ist eh zu teuer.
Also weitersuchen nach unserem
Roadmovie-Star auf vier Rädern.
Ich warte immer,
bis die Leute zu mir kommen.
Das ist so einer meiner Tricks.
Mandy hat heute
einen alten Honda reinbekommen.
Unfallauto zwar, dafür billig.
Die Fahrertür lässt sich
von aussen nicht mehr öffnen.
Aber der Motor ist gut?
- Ja, genau.
Getriebe? Alles gut?
- Ja.
Am Schluss noch weiter verkaufen
ist nicht mit dem.
Das ist die andere Frage, ja.
Irgendwie ... Er spricht zu mir.
- (Lacht) Ja, ich spüre es.
Was sagt er?
Er sagt: "Niemand will mich."
Da sage ich:
"There is a story there!"
Also nichts wie rein in das Ding -
jetzt muss es nur noch
die Probefahrt überstehen.
* Fröhliche Countryklänge:
"Little Bitty" von Alan Jackson *
# A little bitty house
and a little bitty yard.
Yee-haw!
# Well,
it's alright to be little bitty.
# A little hometown
or a big old city.
# Might as well share,
might as well smile,
# life goes on
for a little bitty while.
Riecht ihr auch was?
- Ja.
Ja, das ist unser Auto.
Es könnte ... die Kupplung ...
Oder so was?
Das Fenster
geht auch nicht mehr hoch.
* Sie lachen. *
Okay, it's a pretty shitty car.
Also doch der Taurus.
Schliesslich müssen wir uns
auf die Kiste verlassen -
vielleicht lässt sich
beim Preis ja noch was machen.
Habt ihr was gefunden?
- Ja, einiges.
Aber Ihr Auto
ist in der engeren Auswahl.
Toll.
Nur der Preis ist uns noch zu hoch.
Wir dachten so an ...
... 2'500.
Bar?
- Bar.
Okay, ich mach's.
- Alright.
Wir taufen den Taurus Gotham, weil er
mich an ein New Yorker Taxi erinnert.
Dabei ist New Mexico so ziemlich
das Gegenteil von New York:
wenig Menschen, viel Platz.
Zuerst fahren wir rauf nach Santa Fe,
auf 2'200 m ü.M.
Später wollen wir in den Süden,
an die Grenze zu Mexiko,
die in den letzten Jahren zum
Brennpunkt der Politik geworden ist.
* Sphärische, elektronische Klänge *
Land of Enchantment - Zauberland.
So wird New Mexico auch genannt.
Und weil bekanntlich jedem Anfang
ein Zauber innewohnt,
kommen die Menschen genau darum
hierher: um neu anzufangen,
sich selbst zu verwirklichen,
ihre persönliche Freiheit zu finden.
Nichts ist amerikanischer als das.
Raum dafür gibt's genug:
2 Mio. Einwohner
verteilen sich auf eine Fläche
fast so gross wie Deutschland.
Abseits der Strasse
erstrecken sich einsame Täler,
versteckt hinter Felsenketten.
Hier kann man
herrlich ungestört sein.
Ungestört genug, um die schreck-
lichste Waffe der Welt zu bauen.
Anfang der 1940er-Jahre
erschaffen einige Tausend Forscher
in diesen Bergen die Atombombe.
Der Name der geheimen Mission:
Manhattan Project.
Im Juli 1945
beginnt das Nuklearzeitalter.
In New Mexico wird heute noch
an Atomwaffen getüftelt.
Neugierige Journalisten mit Kameras
sind da natürlich nicht erwünscht.
Top secret.
Darum weiter an den Ort,
dessen Name allein schon
die Westernsehnsucht weckt: Santa Fe.
Mit rund 80'000 Einwohnern
für amerikanische Verhältnisse
eine Kleinstadt.
* Gemächliche Ukuleleklänge *
Gemütliche Urbanität.
Vielleicht zieht das
die Freigeister an,
die aus der halben Welt
nach Santa Fe kommen,
auf der Suche nach Inspiration
zwischen Geschichte und Gegenwart,
zwischen Kultur und Kitsch.
Die erdige Adobe-Architektur
der Pueblo-Indianer
steht dem Erbe aus der Kolonialzeit
gegenüber.
Und was einst europäisch war,
wurde irgendwann amerikanisch.
Doch die erste,
die indianische Zivilisation
ist hier präsenter
als andernorts in den USA.
Dabei wurde den Menschen auch hier
ihr Land mit Gewalt entrissen.
Die Narben, die insbesondere die
Spanier den Indios zugefügt haben,
schmerzen bis heute.
Ich will mit einem der Wortführer
der Ureinwohner darüber reden.
Sein Name ist Lee Moquino,
er lebt im Pueblo Ohkay Owingeh.
Viel mehr wissen wir nicht von ihm.
Unsere Kontaktperson Jaima
will uns zu seinem Haus führen.
Jabaria! Ja, haben wir gefunden.
Fahr hier links, Arthur!
Right here, Arthur.
Und wer sucht, der ... wird gefunden.
* Sirene *
Wir haben Begleitung.
Was ist los?
- Zu schnell gefahren.
Weiss nicht.
Aber so schnell waren wir ja nicht.
Er wird uns gleich sagen,
ob wir zu schnell waren.
Oh, ich habe meine Papiere im Hotel,
scheisse.
Die vom Auto?
- Ja.
Ja, die sollten wir jetzt haben.
Hallo, Sir.
- Hallo, Officer.
Kann ich bitte
Ihren Fahrausweis sehen?
Der ist im Kofferraum,
soll ich ihn holen?
Wir sind aus der Schweiz
und machen eine Reportage.
Waren wir zu schnell?
Nein, nein.
Aber Sie filmten im Wohngebiet -
wir erhielten Anrufe von Bewohnern.
Sie dachten, da wird mit der Kamera
jemandem aufgelauert.
Ah. Wir fuhren da einfach durch,
weil wir ein bestimmtes Haus suchen.
Danke, Sir. Wiedersehen.
Ich war  n i c h t  zu schnell.
Ich weiss. Mein Fehler.
Nach der freundlichen Begegnung
mit der lokalen Stammespolizei
und einer kleinen Odyssee
fahren wir doch noch
zum Haus von Lee Moquino.
Lee, das ist der Reporter
Arthur Honegger.
Freut mich.
- Freut mich.
Und der Regisseur Beat.
Willkommen in unserem Haus.
Thank you.
Lee arbeitet als Lehrer
und Keramikkünstler.
Und ihr kommt aus der Schweiz?
- Ja.
Hi, my name is Arthur.
Er lebt zusammen mit
seiner Grossmutter in einem Trailer.
Heute ist auch Lees Neffe zu Besuch,
gleich gibt's Mittagessen.
Ich freue mich, dass ihr hier seid.
Es gibt Essen:
Suppe im Tontopf gekocht.
Danke! Wir haben gehört,
dass du was Traditionelles machst.
In der Küche unseres Volkes
dreht sich alles um Mais.
Hier ist blauer Mais, hier weisser.
In beiden Suppen
ist auch Chili drin.
Da ist blauer Mais drin?
- Ja. Und Tee gibt's auch.
Ich hatte noch nie blauen Mais.
Ja, das ist eines
unserer traditionellen Gerichte.
Die Familie lebt nicht in
einem traditionellen Adobe-Lehmhaus -
aber in einer traditionellen
Dorfgemeinschaft.
Die steht mit Nachdruck
für ihre Kultur ein.
Auch der Nachwuchs soll wissen,
was es bedeutet,
ein Pueblo-Indianer zu sein.
(Sprechchor) Abolish the Entrada!
Lee ging dafür schon auf die Strasse.
Bist du das?
- Ja, das bin ich.
(Sprechchor) Abolish the Entrada!
Abolish the Entrada!
Wurdest du verhaftet?
Ich nicht,
aber eine Frau wurde verhaftet.
Und dagegen hat Lee protestiert:
die sog. Entrada.
Vor 60 Jahren begannen einige Nach-
kommen der spanischen Kolonialherren,
in historischer Kriegsmontur
durch Santa Fe zu marschieren,
um die Eroberung der Region
zu feiern.
Der Brauch
wurde zusehends umstrittener.
In den letzten Jahren benötigten
die Teilnehmer gar Polizeischutz
in den Strassen der Hauptstadt.
Abolish the Entrada!
Ich  m u s s t e  aufstehen.
Gegen etwas,
das ich für nicht richtig hielt.
Ich wollte nicht,
dass nächste Generationen
das weiter erleben müssen -
die, die nach uns kommen werden.
Weil da Kolonialismus gefeiert wurde?
Genau. Es ist eine Feier
von kolonialer Unterdrückung.
Und das war für mich
nicht mehr akzeptabel.
Das ging so viele Jahre so,
viel zu viele Jahre.
Für mich ist es ein Sinnbild
für all die Probleme,
die wir Indigenen immer noch im
ganzen Land haben - auch heute noch.
Morde an Frauen,
die nicht aufgedeckt werden,
die Ölpipelines,
fehlender Wasserschutz ...
All diese Dinge.
Auch in unserer Dorfgemeinschaft
fanden wir jetzt zu unserer Stimme
und wir sagten:
"Dieses Feiern von Unrecht
wollen wir nicht mehr sehen."
Ihr hattet Erfolg?
- Ja, jetzt.
Nach jahrelangen Protesten.
Eine gute Sache,
dass eure Proteste nun etwas bewirken
und dass ihr gehört werdet.
- Right.
Oh, the dog.
Sorry, buddy.
Wir verabschieden uns von Lee,
dem kämpferischen Indio.
Auf der Fahrt
zurück ins Zentrum von Santa Fe
denke ich über die Freiheit nach.
Sie wirkt so unendlich hier.
Doch die eigene Freiheit, sagt man,
endet dort,
wo die Freiheit des anderen beginnt.
Das ist letztlich der Grund dafür,
dass es die Entrada
heute nicht mehr gibt.
* Rocksong:
"Summertime" von Janis Joplin *
Freiheit kann aber auch heissen,
Zwänge hinter sich zu lassen.
Die Abkehr von gesellschaftlichen
Konventionen -
sie führte in den 60ern und 70ern
Scharen von Hippies nach New Mexico.
Die Kinder dieser Blumenkinder
sind geblieben -
gross geworden in Kommunen,
die landesweit bekannt waren
als Nirwana der Gegenkultur.
Ich frage mich,
was das mit einem macht,
in einer Parallelwelt aufzuwachsen.
Also besuche ich
so ein ehemaliges Hippie-Kind.
Hi, bist du Pilar?
- Die bin ich.
Ich bin Arthur.
- Freut mich.
Willkommen, kommt rein. Hi.
Oh, it's beautiful.
Pilar Law
führt heute in Santa Fe eine Galerie.
Auf dem Foto da rechts bin ich.
- Das bist du?
Ja. Als ich noch ganz klein war.
Eine tolle Aufnahme.
Auf
einer traditionellen Kindertrage.
Einer indianischen Kindertrage.
Wann war das?
- 1967.
Ich war da kaum zwei Monate alt.
Auf diesem Foto ist die Abiquiu
Ranch, wo wir eine Weile lebten.
Und danach - da war ich zwei -
zogen wir in die Kommune
nach Truchas.
Diese Aufnahme entstand in Truchas.
Sie zeigt Janis Joplin
und Tommy Masters.
Ich dachte:
"Sie sieht aus wie Janis Joplin",
aber es ist wirklich Janis Joplin.
Ja, sie besuchte uns
für ein paar Tage.
Was für Leute kamen damals?
Sie kamen von überall her:
von der Ostküste, von Chicago, L.A.
Sie suchten eine neue Erfahrung
in ihrem Leben.
Verbundenheit mit dem Land,
Spiritualität, gesundes Leben.
Und die Indianer
waren dabei sehr wichtig.
Sie haben den Hippies gezeigt,
wie man hier vom eigenen Boden lebt.
Sie mussten erst lernen,
wie Landwirtschaft geht. - Genau.
Schaffe, schaffe, Häusle baue -
nicht eben das Hippie-Klischee
von Sex, Drugs und Rock 'n' Roll.
Die Fotos
hat Pilars Mutter Lisa gemacht -
der Vater, hier auf dem Traktor,
war zuvor Tour-Manager von Bob Dylan.
So. Das ist meine Mutter,
bei einem Powwow in Taos.
Hier in der Mitte ist mein Vater.
- Er baute sein eigenes Haus?
Ja, eine Kommune:
die New-Buffalo-Kommune in Truchas.
Sie existierte sehr lange.
Erst kürzlich wurde sie aufgelöst.
Das sind mein Bruder und ich
im Maisfeld, oben in Truchas.
Wie du siehst: Die Sachen wuchsen
bei uns wirklich hervorragend -
v.a. die alten indianischen Sorten.
So hatte meine Mutter mich gebadet.
Auf dem alten Holzherd?
Das sieht alles
total ruhig und friedlich aus.
Bist du gern so aufgewachsen?
- Ja, ich liebte es.
Was toll ist, wenn du so aufwächst:
Du entwickelst
dein eigenes Vorstellungsvermögen.
Du kannst dich selber unterhalten.
Ich verbrachte meine Zeit
in den Bäumen, mit den Tieren.
In meinen eigenen Abenteuern,
Entdeckungsreisen und Geschichten.
Und in der Nacht
konntest du die Milchstrasse sehen -
das ganze Universum.
In dem aufzuwachsen, gibt dir
eine Verbundenheit mit der Erde,
einen Sinn dafür, wer du bist.
Du schätzt, was du hast.
Das gab mir Wurzeln.
Und ich kann da immer wieder hin,
um mich zu sammeln.
Ich möchte jetzt
nicht esoterisch sein, aber ...
Nein, nein. Ich weiss, was du meinst.
... aber es ist wahr! Wir sind
Teil davon. Das ist unser Leben.
Wir sind Teil der Erde.
Ohne die Erde
wären wir ja gar nicht hier.
Yes. We're all related.
Die Kommune New Buffalo
wurde kürzlich aufgelöst -
vom Zeitgeist überwuchert.
Santa Fe, bekannt als City Different,
ist heute
in vielerlei Hinsicht angepasst.
Doch die Gegenkultur hat überlebt.
Im Industriegebiet der Stadt etwa
in besonders experimenteller Form.
So etwas erwartet man im abgelegenen
New Mexico eigentlich nicht.
Meow Wolf ist ein Projekt
von 400 Künstlern,
frei und schräg -
und extrem erfolgreich.
In nur drei Jahren wurde dieser Ort
zum Must für Besucher von Santa Fe.
Hallo, wie geht's?
- Hi.
Ich bin Arthur.
- Marisa.
It's a pleasure.
- Welcome!
Schön,
schaut ihr auch bei uns vorbei.
Es macht mir viel Spass,
zu vermitteln, was wir hier tun.
Wir werden immer grösser.
Immer mehr Kreative kommen hierher.
Irgendetwas
scheint hier in der Luft zu liegen,
das die kreativen Geister anzieht?
- Absolut.
In Los Angeles
erstickst du im Verkehr,
alles ist schwierig und gestresst.
Und dann kommst du hierher und hast
gleich eine andere Lebensqualität.
Fantastische Landschaften, kreative
Leute - wie George R.R. Martin.
Er schrieb hier "Game of Thrones",
inspiriert von der Gegend.
Martin hat den miauenden Wölfen auch
finanziell auf die Beine geholfen.
Aus einer alten Bowling-Halle wurde
so das Haus der ewigen Rückkehr.
Ich muss euch sagen: Falls ihr in
unserem Multiversum verloren geht,
übernehmen wir keine Verantwortung.
Damit wir am Ende
wieder zurückfinden,
begleitet uns Mat Crimmins -
einer der Künstler hier.
(Elektronische, verzerrte Männer-
stimme) Hallo und willkommen.
Geben Sie acht, wo Sie hingehen -
und v.a.:
Verlieren Sie nie den Verstand!
(Mat) Willkommen
im Haus der ewigen Rückkehr.
Es ist tatsächlich
ein richtiges Haus.
Die Idee ist:
Du betrittst ein fremdes Haus,
in dem immer noch Leute wohnen -
oder mal gewohnt haben.
Du kannst Schubladen öffnen,
Zeitschriften liegen rum,
da und dort ein Computer.
In allem kannst du herumstöbern
und so vielleicht etwas über die
Geschichte dieses Hauses erfahren.
* Psychedelische Klänge *
Ein bisschen Geisterbahn,
ein bisschen Installation,
ein bisschen Detektivspiel.
In der Küche finde ich
erste Spuren der Geschichte,
die Mat und seine Freunde
hier versteckt haben.
Jemand starb.
2016.
Wenn jemand von euch hungrig ist:
Sorry, der Kühlschrank ist leer.
* Psychedelische, geflüsterte Stimmen
mit Echo *
(Elektronische, hallende
Frauenstimme) Ich bin Alma.
Ich bin dein gate agent
und helfe dir, dein Ziel zu wählen.
Dein Ziel heisst: Oridian Heights.
Bitte begib dich in Raum Nummer 4!
Nummer 4 ... Hier.
So eine Tür
wollte ich schon immer mal.
Irgendwas zwischen "Star Trek"
und "Poltergeist".
Und äh ... "Tischlein deck dich"?
Daneben ein Schulbus,
der aus dem Boden wächst.
So muss sich ein LSD-Trip anfühlen.
(Elektronische Frauenstimme)
Ich habe meinen Sohn verloren.
Siehst du das schwebende Kind?
Was ist mit dem Kind passiert?
Vielleicht von Aliens entführt?
Oder waren's doch Geister?
Das Haus gibt eine Menge Fragen auf.
Antworten gibt es keine,
dafür ein pures Fantasy-Erlebnis.
Das nächste Multiversum
entsteht jetzt in Las Vegas.
Las Vegas ...
Das ist auch das Amerikanische,
dass man daraus ein Unternehmen macht
und sagt: "Hey, damit
können wir auch Geld verdienen."
Die ganze Merchandise hier.
Das ist, denke ich, auch
einer der Unterschiede zu Europa,
wo man als Künstler sagt:
"Nein, kein Kommerz."
Da sagt man hier: "Das geht auch."
Ja, hier geht irgendwie alles.
Das ist ja auch das Versprechen
von New Mexico: "Anything goes."
Nur die eigenen Regeln gelten -
ein Ort der Befreiung eben.
Ein Ort, an dem morgen
schon alles anders sein kann.
Auch das Wetter, wie wir merken.
Jetzt muss er nur noch anspringen,
der gute Gotham.
Eiskalt ist alles.
* Piepen, Motor *
Oh.
Jetzt ist es plötzlich weiss
im Südwesten der USA.
Und wir mit Sommerreifen unterwegs.
Gut, geht's heute noch in den Süden.
Hier müssen wir
aber unbedingt noch Halt machen.
Wegen Jane.
Respektive wegen Janes Business.
Sie hat nämlich ein so richtig
zeitloses Geschäftsmodell.
Hallo, Jungs.
- Hey, sind Sie Jane?
Kommen Sie rein!
Das ist der Saloon,
das Hauptgebäude im Ort.
Und was wurde hier alles gedreht?
- Was wurde nicht hier gedreht?
Janes Ranch dient als Filmkulisse,
eigenes Western-Städtchen inklusive.
Den ersten Film machten wir 1985:
"Silverado".
Das ist das Gute an Western-Filmen:
Sie werden nie alt.
Sie werden zu Klassikern,
Sie haben recht.
Was schlagen Sie vor?
Schauen wir uns das an?
Ja, das können wir versuchen.
Hier hängen die Stars rum.
Buchstäblich.
Hallo, mein Lieber.
Ist jemand drüben?
Ich habe hier Leute
von einer Firma aus Deutschland.
Sie möchten gerne ein paar Bilder
vom Städtchen machen,
mit einer Drohne.
Es wird ein Dokumentarfilm und wir
bekommen damit jede Menge Werbung.
Darauf können Sie wetten.
"Darauf können Sie wetten", sagt er.
Durch die Bonanza Creek Ranch
ritten schon Stars wie John Wayne,
Robert Redford oder Penelope Cruz.
Heute aber ist es ruhig im Ort -
gespenstisch ruhig.
Wow.
* Gemächliche Mundharmonika-
und Gitarrenklänge *
Nur mit einer Kamera bewaffnet
laufe ich durch den Wilden Westen.
Ich bin ja froh, ist niemand da,
um mich zum Duell herauszufordern.
Hier könnte man ewig drehen.
Doch die Strasse ruft.
* Fröhliche Countryklänge:
"Little Bitty" von Alan Jackson *
# Have a little love
on a little honeymoon.
# You got a little dish
and you got a little spoon.
# A little bitty house
and a little bitty yard.
# A little bitty dog
and a little bitty car.
# Well,
it's alright to be little bitty.
Alright. Honegger?
Spricht sich Ihr Name so aus?
Bitte kommen Sie mit
zu meinem Wagen.
Und bringen Sie
Ihre Wagenpapiere mit.
Ja - es ist sein Auto. Hast du sie?
- Ja, habe ich.
Okay.
Er sagte, weil's so kalt ist,
können wir im Auto warten.
Ja, was ... Was denkst du?
Wir waren über 100 und hier ist 75.
Ui.
Es ging halt nur geradeaus.
- Ja, das ...
Verlockend. Und die anderen
fuhren ja auch so schnell.
True, true.
Ausgerechnet uns hat er rausgeholt.
* Tür geht auf. *
Kannst du's bezahlen?
Warte mal:
Steht hier ein Betrag drauf?
Wir können ja raten wie viel.
Steht da was drauf?
Es war nur eine Verwarnung.
Hat nix gegeben.
Echt jetzt?
- Ja.
Das Glück,
wenn man in den USA Ausländer ist.
Aber jetzt müssen wir
ziemlich korrekt fahren.
Deswegen
sollten wir uns auch anschnallen.
Alle sollten sich jetzt anschnallen.
- Auch hinten?
* Elektronische, dynamische Klänge *
500 km von Santa Fe entfernt
liegt Mexiko.
Puerto Palomas heisst das Städtchen,
Taubenhafen.
Klingt lieblich,
ist an einem Novembermorgen
um 5.30 Uhr aber v.a. eins:
kalt.
Wir drehen einen Dokumentarfilm
über die Kinder,
die drüben zur Schule gehen.
Okay.
Die holen bei Ihnen Frühstück?
- Ja.
Ist das Kaffee?
- Nein, Atole.
Atole. Suppe.
- Atole? Suppe?
Ja, aus Keksen.
- Keks-Suppe?
Mh.
Wie ist es?
- Ist gut.
Also, schmeckt ein bisschen wie ...
Kakao oder so.
Der falsche Kakao aus verwässerten
Keksen wärmt mich ein wenig.
Die Grenzgänger hier,
die sind ein raues Klima gewohnt -
und das von Kindesbeinen an.
Morgen für Morgen spielt sich hier
die gleiche Szene ab:
Hunderte Autos
bringen Kinder an die Grenze.
Sie leben zwar in Mexiko, gehen aber
drüben in den USA zur Schule,
weil sie
amerikanische Staatsbürger sind.
Der Grenzübergang,
das ist ihr Schulweg.
Alltag ist das auch
für die achtjährige Hema
und ihre Mutter Laura.
Guten Morgen. Wie geht es euch?
- Gut. - Gut.
Warum musst du so früh hier sein?
Es ist jetzt 6 Uhr.
Weil ... Wenn ich so früh bin, dann
verpasse ich sicher nicht den Bus.
Manchmal durchsuchen sie
ihre Rucksäcke
auf Drogen oder Waffen
und solche Sachen.
Dann untersuchen sie alle Rucksäcke.
- Alle Rücksäcke? Wow.
Und das dauert eine Weile.
Dann dauert es länger.
Bei Hunderten Kindern
alle Rucksäcke durchsuchen ...
Also: 30 Min. bis hierher.
Ihr seid dann um 6 Uhr hier.
Der Bus fährt los um 7 Uhr.
Die Fahrt geht 45 Min.
Die Schule beginnt um ...
- ... 8 Uhr.
Wow, das ist wirklich lange.
Und das jeden Tag?
- Jeden Tag.
Bist du glücklich, dass du
in den USA zur Schule gehen kannst?
Ja, ich bin froh.
- Was ist besser dort?
Der Englischunterricht
und die Lehrer.
Die Schulen hier in Mexiko
sind teuer.
Und die Schüler kriegen von
den Lehrern wenig Aufmerksamkeit.
Ist es heiss im Sommer,
gibt's keine Klimaanlage.
Und im Winter gibt's keine Heizung.
Keine Heizung?
- Nein.
Wow.
Wie unterschiedlich das Leben doch
ist, je nachdem wo man aufwächst.
Von den Chancen, die sich
wenige Meter weiter im Norden auftun,
können die meisten anderen Kids
in Mexiko nur träumen.
Ich muss an meine Tochter denken,
die gleich alt ist wie Hema,
und an den Schulweg zu Hause.
Am Zoll selber
durften wir nicht filmen.
Viel ist auch nicht passiert:
Der Übergang war problemlos.
Rucksackkontrollen
gab es heute keine.
Das sind aber viele Schüler.
Ja, wir müssen hier immer aufpassen
bei so vielen Kindern.
Dass ihr da
auf den richtigen Bus kommt. - Ja.
Hey. Vorsicht!
* Kreischen, Lachen *
He, das ist meine Decke.
Du magst nicht teilen? Aber es gibt
doch viel wärmer, wenn man teilt.
Zu zweit unter der Decke.
Sie ist meine beste Freundin.
Ich will nicht, dass ihr den Bus
verpasst. Danke euch vielmals.
Hema, das hat Spass gemacht.
Geniesst den Tag!
Auf Wiedersehen.
- Thank you.
Bye!
* Leise, nachdenkliche Klänge *
Fliegen müsste man können.
Dann wäre die Grenze
nur eine Linie in der Landschaft.
Wir fahren weiter -
Richtung Osten, dieser Linie entlang.
Gut zu erkennen
am meterhohen Stahlzaun,
der die beiden Länder,
die beiden Welten trennt.
Unser Ziel ist die Gegend,
in der New Mexico, Mexiko und Texas
aufeinandertreffen.
Gegenüber von El Paso
liegt Ciudad Juarez,
wo täglich Flüchtlinge ankommen,
die von den USA träumen.
Damit wir mit diesen Menschen auch
sprechen können, brauchen wir Hilfe.
Hallo, bist du Monica?
Ich bin Arthur, freut mich.
Monica, schön dich zu sehen.
Noch auf US-Boden, in El Paso,
treffen wir die Fotografin
Monica Lozano.
Sie dokumentiert seit Jahren
das Schicksal der Flüchtlinge
in dieser Gegend.
Sie nimmt uns mit nach Mexiko,
nach Juarez.
Du bist hier aufgewachsen?
Ja, ich bin in El Paso geboren
und in Juarez aufgewachsen.
Alles gleich nebeneinander.
Juarez ist dort drüben.
Alles ganz nah.
Schau hier links:
die Universität von Texas.
Hier sind Wissen und Bildung.
Und rechts der ärmste und
gefährlichste Stadtteil von Juarez:
Anapra.
Die Leute von Anapra
sehen täglich auf dieses Versprechen
von einem besseren Leben.
Aber da ist ein Zaun,
und sie können das nicht erreichen.
Die Bilder von Monica Lozano führen
in extremer Klarheit vor Augen,
was Migranten durchmachen,
was Flucht bedeutet.
* Einzelne, intensive Töne *
Mich interessiert immer,
warum Menschen auf der Flucht sind.
Denn es ist die schwerste Reise,
die jemand machen kann,
sich auf die Flucht zu begeben.
Im texanischen El Paso
gehören sie zum Stadtbild:
Männer, die sich
nach dem illegalen Grenzübertritt
als Tagelöhner durchschlagen.
Sie machen praktisch jede Arbeit
zu praktisch jedem Lohn.
Wir kommen nun zur Grenze
und zur Brücke nach Juarez.
Wir müssen hier was zahlen.
5 $ kostet die Fahrt über die Brücke.
Monica hat einen Grenzgängerausweis
und darf darum
die Schnellspur benutzen.
Pässe werden nicht verlangt -
wir überqueren den Rio Grande
zwischen den USA und Mexiko
genauso selbstverständlich
wie den Rhein
zwischen der Schweiz und Deutschland.
Es ist für mich ganz normal,
über die Grenze zu fahren.
Ich mache es fast täglich.
Oft bringe ich meine Kinder mit,
manchmal kaufe ich hier ein.
Weil es günstiger ist?
- Es ist günstiger.
Und ich mag die richtigen Tortillas,
den Käse, das gute Essen.
Und jetzt sehen wir
die andere Seite des Stahlzauns.
Er hat eine Botschaft
an Migranten aus dem Süden:
bis hierhin und nicht weiter.
Menschen auf der Flucht
betrachten Juarez dennoch
höchstens als Zwischenstation.
Bevor sie versuchen,
in die USA zu kommen,
verbringen viele einige Nächte
in der Casa del Migrante.
Monica kommt oft
in diese Notunterkunft,
um die Geschichten der Flucht
festzuhalten.
Das sind Freunde,
Journalisten aus der Schweiz.
Ich bin Flores. Herzlich willkommen.
Bienvenidos, bienvenidos.
- Gracias.
Hola, como estan?
- Hola.
Seid ihr einverstanden,
ein Interview zu geben?
Ja, sie wollen mit euch reden.
Woher kommt ihr? Aus El Salvador?
Haben Sie schon versucht,
in die USA zu kommen?
* Sie dolmetscht auf Spanisch. *
Ja, sie waren
auf der Zaragoza-Grenzbrücke.
Und wurden jetzt hierher gebracht,
weil es hier nachts wärmer ist.
Es ist kalt draussen für ein Baby.
Zwei Wochen ist es her, seit diese
Familie ihre Heimat verlassen musste.
Die Bandengewalt hatte
das Leben zur Hölle gemacht.
Es war am Dienstag, vorletzte Woche.
Wir waren zu Hause,
als ein paar Leute vorbeikamen.
Sie sagten, dass jemand tot sei
und dass sie glauben,
dass es mein Lebensgefährte ist.
Wir haben es nicht geglaubt.
Aber dann ging ich
mit meiner Familie doch hin
und habe gesehen, dass es
der Vater meiner Tochter ist.
Sie haben ihm
die Haut vom Kopf gerissen.
Sie haben ihn erwürgt,
Hände und Füsse waren gefesselt.
Die Tochter hört schweigend zu,
während die Mutter
den Albtraum beschreibt,
vor dem die beiden geflohen sind.
Diese Menschen suchen nicht einfach
ein besseres Leben in den USA.
Sie müssen völlig neu anfangen,
an einem völlig fremden Ort.
Auch die Familie aus Guatemala.
Wir wollen jetzt
zum Migrationsbüro in den USA.
Wenn sie uns die Möglichkeit geben,
rüberzugehen, dann gehen wir.
Habt ihr davon gehört, dass sie die
Leute nicht über die Grenze lassen?
Oder dass sie Kinder
von ihren Eltern trennen?
Habt ihr davon gehört?
Ja, davon haben wir gehört.
Aber wir vertrauen auf Gott,
dass sie uns nicht trennen werden.
Gibt es auch eine andere Möglichkeit
rüberzukommen?
* Monica dolmetscht auf Spanisch. *
Darüber haben wir uns
noch keine Gedanken gemacht.
Wir wissen, dass man auch
durch die Wüste gehen kann.
Aber wir wollen das Leben unseres
Kindes nicht aufs Spiel setzen.
Wie geht's dir, Kleine?
- Gut.
Wie alt bist du?
- Neun.
Bist du müde?
- Fast nicht.
Nein?
She says she's not tired,
that she feels good.
She's nine years old.
Geht's dir hier gut?
Fühlst du dich sicher?
Si?
Und Mexiko? Was denkst du?
N...
Was fühlst du?
Die beiden Familien haben nun
schon mal ein Dach über dem Kopf,
und sie erhalten Informationen
über die Einreise in die USA.
Was die Migranten dann tun - Asyl in
den Vereinigten Staaten beantragen,
versuchen illegal über die Grenze zu
kommen oder hier in Mexiko bleiben,
das ist ihre Entscheidung.
* Nachdenkliche, ruhige Klänge *
Monica fährt mit uns dorthin,
wo häufig Menschen versuchen,
auf die andere Seite zu kommen.
Die andere Seite. Das Zauberland.
Versprechen der grossen Freiheit.
Das bedeutet hier etwas anderes.
Das ist er.
Dieser Zaun zieht sich bereits
über weite Strecken
des Grenzverlaufs
zwischen Mexiko und den USA.
Nur wenige Abschnitte
sind noch offen.
Etwa entlang des Rio Grande?
- Ja.
Wir haben hier eine Stelle,
da hat ein Künstler
die Metallwand blau angemalt.
Um die Wand
optisch verschwinden zu lassen -
sie wird zu einem Teil des Himmels.
Yeah, I can see why.
Auf der anderen Seite
findest du immer wieder Schuhe,
allerlei Dinge von Leuten,
die da rüber sind.
Links die USA, rechts Mexiko.
Gleiche Landschaft, ungleiche Länder.
Drüben macht sich
die Grenzpolizei bereit.
Ist das eine Kamera,
die die da aufbauen?
Sieht aus wie ein Scheinwerfer.
- Ah, für die Nacht.
Für die Nacht.
Denkst du, der Zaun hält Leute
davon ab, über die Grenze zu gehen?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Sie können es ja vor sich sehen,
ganz nah.
Ja, ganz nah.
Wenn man so nahe dran steht,
kann man auch nachvollziehen,
dass man nicht umkehrt und sagt:
"Okay,
da ist noch eine Mauer dazwischen."
Die ist einfach nur noch eines
von den vielen Hindernissen,
die diese Leute überwinden.
Ein Hindernis.
Ein Kunstwerk.
Eine Mauer.
Was sind Grenzen eigentlich?
Linien in der Landschaft, letztlich.
Doch wer die Freiheit sucht
oder vor Unfreiheit flieht,
will nur einer Linie folgen -
der eigenen.
Es wird langsam Abend, wir müssen
zurück auf die texanische Seite.
Auf dem Rückweg darf uns Monica
mit ihrem Grenzgängerausweis
nicht mitnehmen -
also reisen wir zu Fuss ein
in die USA.
Mit Blick auf den Rio Grande.
Der Schweizer Pass
macht es uns einfach.
Gentlemen. Switzerland.
- Thank you.
So viel einfacher als den Familien
aus Guatemala und El Salvador.
Bevor wir goodbye sagen, wollen wir
unseren Gotham noch verkaufen.
Was ist unsere Ansage, Arthur?
- Unsere Ansage?
Ja, Verkaufspreis?
3'000.
Genau, oder?
- Ja, 500 mehr als wir bezahlt haben.
Was ist das? "Discount Auto".
Okay, gehen wir da mal hin.
Ich heisse Arthur. Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Gut, und Ihnen?
Wir haben das Auto vor einer Woche
in Albuquerque gekauft.
Für eine Sendung
fürs Schweizer Fernsehen.
Und wozu die Kamera?
Wir drehen alles dokumentarisch.
Vom Kauf bis zum Verkauf.
Ich weiss nicht ...
Ich bin nicht interessiert.
Nicht interessiert? Aber das ist
ein Ford Taurus, ein Klassiker!
Nein.
Ich will dein Gesicht - mir gefällt
nicht, was hier passiert.
Sie vertrauen uns nicht?
- Nein.
"Bezahlbare Automiete" -
"Rio-Bravo-Autoverkauf".
Das ist unser Ort.
Okay, Interesse besteht schon mal.
Und Macken wird der jetzt wohl
auch keine finden -
lief schliesslich wie eine Eins,
der Motor.
Doch es bleibt beim Beschnüffeln.
Ah well, that's life.
Mercy, have mercy!
Wir sollen aufhören zu filmen?
Kein Problem.
Ich finde raus, wer ihr seid.
- Danke.
Haut ab!
Okay.
Next try.
Seid ihr interessiert?
- Nein.
Warum nicht?
Fährt gut, klassisches Design.
Ist es nicht.
Sie kauften den Wagen in Albuquerque
und wollen ihn jetzt loswerden.
Und die Wagenpapiere?
Ja, klar, die haben wir.
Die hast du, oder?
Eben nicht wirklich:
Die Originalpapiere haben wir nicht.
Die wollte uns
der Verkäufer nachschicken,
bis jetzt ist aber nichts angekommen.
Die Kopie auf dem Handy
überzeugt hier nicht.
Was ist der Höchstpreis,
den ihr uns bieten könnt?
Ich kaufe kein Auto
ohne alle Wagenpapiere.
So wie das lief, glaube ich nicht,
dass irgendein car dealer
uns dieses Auto abnimmt.
Was tun? Verschrotten
bringen wir nicht übers Herz.
Also fahren wir zur einzigen Person,
die wir in dieser Ecke des Landes
näher kennen.
Telefonisch haben wir sie
schon mal vorgewarnt.
Monica! Wie geht es dir?
Wir sind zurück.
Ihr seid zurück.
Schön, euch wiederzusehen.
Du musst diesem Mann
ein Auto abkaufen.
Ich hoffe,
ich bin vertrauenswürdig genug.
Was ist passiert?
Wir haben bei mehreren Händlern
versucht, es zu verkaufen.
Doch wir konnten beim Kauf
nicht auf alle Papiere warten -
wir mussten ja losfahren.
Darum wollte es uns jetzt
kein Händler abkaufen.
Aber es ist ein gutes Auto.
Und ihr stellt es einfach
vor mein Haus? Ihr seid verrückt.
Ja. Und ich weiss: Du bist verrückt
genug, es zu kaufen.
Ja, ich kenne tatsächlich
mittellose Leute ohne Auto,
die dieses Auto
wirklich gebrauchen könnten.
Für ihr tägliches Leben.
Studenten, Familien.
Ich helfe euch aus.
Danke.
Den Preis
musst du mit Beat verhandeln.
Symbolischer Preis: 1 $.
Yes, that's good.
Adios, New Mexico.
* Fröhliche Countryklänge:
"Little Bitty" von Alan Jackson *